survived the carnage
but lost her husband her son and her
daughter
they were on their way to hualien for
the annual tomb sweeping day
a traditional chinese festival she
remembers hearing a loud bang
just before the train entered the tunnel
it was like a living hell our carriage
was mangled things had fallen off and
piled on top of passengers
shelves fell on top of me it was dark
the train had crashed into a
construction truck that had slid down a
hill and onto the track
just minutes earlier
i got hold of a mobile phone and turned
on the torch to try to find my husband
and children
i saw them but there was nothing i could
do to get them out
so many objects piled on top of them i
tried to remove some of the things such
as iron bars
but there was just too much stuff and
when i did a voice kept
asking me not to move anything because
it hurt him
so i just sat still chung was rescued an
hour later
president chai engun visited a hospital
where dozens of the injured are being
treated
and promised a thorough investigation
into the accident
as well as government support to
affected families
this distressing accident caused heavy
casualties i came to hualien today to
visit our wounded
and express my sympathy to the families
of the victims
officials have said the driver may have
failed to properly apply the brakes of
the construction truck
prosecutors have sought an arrest
warrant for the manager of the company
that carries out trackside maintenance
a court has released the man on a bond
workers are still trying to remove the
more heavily damaged sections of the
train
that remain inside the tunnel as taiwan
marks a second day of mourning
families of the crash victims gathered
at the site of the disaster on
saturday to say prayers conduct
religious rights
and grieve for those they've lost
florence louis al jazeera